so I see there's a bunch of lowlifes on
my Instagram tonight talking Kim Zolciak
slams the haters as daughter Brielle
shows off her new man the 38 year old
don't be tardy star posted some hot pics
to social media over the holiday weekend
showing off her star-spangled spirit in
an itty-bitty red bikini and like
clockwork
got a ton of backlash on Instagram from
the haters one wrote this is seriously
one of the worst photoshopped photos
I've ever seen it's so annoying be
yourself show you guys really what I
look like I'm not a book the mother of
six slammed the naysayers on snapchat
with two more bikini shots with the
caption as you can see I don't have to
Photoshop anything a little bathing suit
from Beach bunnies meanwhile Kim's
daughter Brielle has been getting plenty
of attention on social media herself but
not because of her bikini selfies the 19
year old reality star has a new
boyfriend
20 year old boston redsox minor league
pitcher michael kopeck the two have been
posting adorable pics together on their
social media accounts you go girl